ciao a tutti importante solo io ho detto
anita perché è una cosa importante e
quindi ciao ciao
non so perché ho fatto è stata oggi un
video diverso spavento perché vi
dobbiamo parlare di una cosa è una cosa
che vi abbiamo mostrato nascosto da un
po di tutto il con il tempo rimasto è il
momento di parlarne
finalmente stiamo passato questo video
mi dispiace vi ha tenuto sulle spine con
questo countdown
se mi seguite su instagram o della
community di youtube ho messo un
countdown solo di tre giorni c'è chi non
fa list 85 giorni 102 zombie io ho
deciso di lasciarli sulle spine solo per
tre giorni che è stato divertente
regioni commenti da parte mia
troppo carini allora il sommerso il
cuore in questo progetto in più vitale e
stato un grandissimo aiuto percorso
bellissimo e mi ha sostenuto in tutto il
progetto fatto gravissimo supporto
grazie e senza girarci troppo intorno
da oggi potete preordinare il mio libro
alcuni di voi già indovinato e alcuni di
voi chiedevano costantemente ti prego
alida feih1 hackett 15 potrebbe contrari
così possiamo veramente ricette
ebbene sì eccolo qua lo trovate in
descrizione nella descrizione in questo
video trovate il pre ordine su amazon
questa è la copertina del libro è come
potete vedere ci sono vari slime ma non
solo non ci saranno solo star ma ci sono
anche dei fai da te e altre sorprese
insomma c'è nomi a parte di me in cui
scoprirete varie curiosità ste di me
cose che non sapete
perché non vi immaginate se si utilizza
in questo libro sono comunque uniche e
speciali e sono sicura vi piaceranno un
tacco perché io ho scelti anche in base
ai vostri gusti e scelte insomma ho
pensato dell'islam fantastici che
potessero piacere o poi che piace essere
un tanto a me che facessero dei suoni mr
che fossero bellissimi anche di aspetto
anche degli states accolla insomma
abbiamo questo il cuore in questo
progetto di quella che vi piacerà un
sacco ma la cosa che mi emoziona più di
tutti sapete qual è che penso che avrete
capito eventi finalmente sì potremmo
incontrare mi chiedete da due o tre anni
di incontrarmi e sapete che un po
difficile non è freddo in italia però
ora finalmente si potrebbe incontrare
perchè però in tour in italia allora
ancora non ho le date date e le città
mi raccomando seguitemi sinistra con
sentenza abbiamo comunque seguiti passo
youtube di annunciano le date sia su
youtube che su instagram 1 kg veneti non
tre
[Musica]
ora con me grazie un forte finalmente un
motore di vedrete ha fatto impazzire
durissimi abbracciarli tutti talmente
descrizione amazon e ibs tutte già
effettuare il preordine se volete
appunto essere i primi ad avere il libro
servito il preordine siete via tutto i
primi avrei libro mandare oppure loud su
instagram e andrò vederli tutti che
quando mi tante mozzicone non riesce più
a parlare ea dormire mettete felici come
noi
sì perché siete forse tantissime più voi
ei andrebbe appunto vi darò più
informazioni sulle date di firma copie
non puoi terrore rincontrarli più bello
fatemi sapere tutto nei commenti e ora
vi lascio con quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per le nostre altre challenge
il video di ieri il video di domani le
nostre complesse di video divertenti e
vi mando un enorme a umani ciao
[Musica]